[Música]
[Aplausos]
la cárcel de gorgona era muy tenaz ya
porque usted quedaba totalmente en todo
el sentido de la palabra aislado no
solamente del territorio no desde su
familia
[Música]
era muy difícil que los reclusos se
escaparan de gorgona porque la
la isla estaba llena de reptiles
venenosos
muchas tarántulas venenosas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los internos moría muchas veces de
inanición falta de comida
morían de infecciones gastrointestinales
y
y los internos muchos
vivían en estado depresivo
[Música]
y me parece que recuperar la historia de
esto darle a conocer al mundo y a
colombia hace parte
indudablemente de la verdad que hoy se
busca como instrumento de reconciliación
entre los colombianos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ya no lo hay